you had mentioned that and clearly
everybody knows this politics is a very
dirty business beyond and you got caught
up in it as bad as anybody
um
but what you dealt with is that just hey
it's politics as usual hey welcome to
the game
or is there something specific about
chicago illinois politics
then dirtier than most states i think
four governors of the state of illinois
have been in jail including the governor
preceding you governor ryan uh your arch
nemesis uh mike madigan i believe his
name is embroiled in political turmoil
you see what's going on in chicago and
you know they calling it shy rack and
just everything that's that's happening
there my question is what the hell is
going on in chicago and in illinois yeah
the the answer is is it worse corruption
more endemic in a place like chicago and
illinois than in other places the answer
is yes and no
it is far more so than let's say our
neighboring state to the north wisconsin
their politics their government's a lot
cleaner no doubt about that but it's not
that different from washington that's
the sad reality i mean you think about
the stuff that happens in chicago mike
madigan they all got rich
madigan's is the former speaker been
speaking since 1983 been a state rep
since 1973. the same time biden became a
united states senator right well both of
those guys got super rich in the job how
does that happen if you're doing it
straight right so when i think about
biden and hunter biden and the
allegations relating to the biden family
in china i think about the bush family
in china and their economic interests i
think about going to war in iraq and we
were lied to about weapons of mass
destruction and dick cheney's the vice
president and halliburton and they break
that country up and then he his company
gets in there to rebuild it i think
about that sort of stuff and i think
chicago and illinois isn't that much
different from washington there are
states that are much
better straight cleaner illinois is not
one of them but it's not that different
in washington than it is it's funny i
just pulled the illinois the most
corrupt states in america okay
you gotta see this type in the following
word
uh the most corrupt states in america
it's a it's a uh
forbes article the most corrupt states
in america
it's it's by a mile there you go click
on that one go a little lower
go look at that make it make it bigger
number one is dc look at that yeah
number of federal public corruption
convictions per 10 000 inhabitants from
1976 to 2018
dc's like the wayne gretzky of
corruption you know they're just
crushing number two they're not even a
state
no it's not and then it's illinois's
third then tennessee new york
pennsylvania virginia ohio
jersey uh georgia next on that list and
so these aren't red or blue it's not
like they're all blue states or red
states so how do you interpret this uh
map right here
you know
i don't really know a lot about what's
going on in louisiana i'm not surprised
with some of the history there right
a lot of it is tradition and customary
practices okay
and illinois customary practices here
again i'm the only one who didn't get
rich in that business because i wasn't
like those other people they do it
through legal corruption they pass the
laws that benefit themselves their law
practices and they get really rich
but
i would say this about illinois illinois
is so corrupt politically that even our
u.s attorneys can be corrupt like those
corrupt [ __ ] who did to me what
they did they're dirty rotten scumbags
and they're corrupt and they abuse the
rule of law and instead of going after
the real corruption and maybe what's
happening now with manikin that's
happening instead of going after the
real corruption they went after a guy so
they can look like they did something
because i had a high office and they
make names for themselves and they just
add another governor to the list of the
trophies that they win so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]